dos días después de iniciado el proceso
el pasado 8 de septiembre Nancy está
chilena que perdió a su hijo Luis Felipe
en la sala de conciertos bataclan
aterrizaba en París
no tenía abogado tampoco se había
constituido en partes civil y ni
siquiera tenía unas vacunas reconocidas
por Francia Pero sabía que quería estar
presente
en estos meses Nancy consiguió un
abogado que hable español pero también
se armó toda una vida en París
este hotel que paga el estado francés se
ha convertido en su casa
esta gente me ha cogido súper bien bueno
por tanto tiempo que permaneció acá pero
han sido para mí súper súper súper
acogedores Y le expliqué
estoy en el proceso por lo tanto
necesito permanecer en un lugar mucho
tiempo y bueno me preguntaron por qué
que si yo entonces yo empecé a explicar
y ellos tienen esto estos atentados muy
en la retina
esto fueron muy afectados por esto
en el escritorio de la pequeña
habitación revistas y libros que hablan
de este proceso fuera de lo común son un
regalo de un policía su intérprete o la
madre de otra de las víctimas he tenido
mucha mucha información
respecto a cómo pasó en el patatlán como
entraron al bataclan Yo me imagino cómo
murió mi hijo
horrible cada día de forma religiosa
nancia si está el proceso sólo faltó en
febrero Cuando regresó a Chile para
conocer a su nieto pero también porque
necesitaba urgentemente hacer una pausa
en la recta final la chilena considera
que las penas que pidieron los fiscales
no son lo suficientemente severas yo
venía con otras expectativas que estos
tipos No salieron nunca más de la cárcel
que
porque todo para mí todos son culpa uno
en mayor o menor medida pero todo
contribuyeron para que todo esto pasara
tras cada audiencia la carga se aliviana
en parte Gracias a la conversación con
otros familiares en el patio de la corte
Nancy tiene ahora más información que
cuando llegó Aunque muchas dudas No han
sido resueltas